alright sorry Wow welcome to to a new
video and I decided sort of
spontaneously did to do some fun video
here which you shouldn't take too
seriously in terms of quality because um
I just joined a bullet tournament here
on CH s cube one minute per game no
increment or anything so don't expect
wonders in terms of quality but I hope
it will have some nice action here so
let's go first game I didn't didn't play
bullet yet this evening so first games
usually are quite shaky from my
experience okay you take b2 and dumb mm
trying to arrest this queen of it
alright so grab here now I have a nicely
positioned bishop on g6 alright I cannot
really prevent the Queen trade but still
should be nice for me undressing the
night
yeah I don't want to allow him to get
the King out of the middle so the
bishops station stays on c5 the bishop s
not bury the rookie want to follow most
likely
technology 79 which get lost now oops
let's grab this here all right someone
already want two games so I don't don't
I'm not so vicious in terms of winning
this tournament with comments I usually
play crap bullet so let's hope it works
out at least a bit they also note that
this has got done this time time
handicaps so I'm already low on time in
from the start yeah saw that but I
wanted to get rid of this bishop okay it
doesn't take even okay maybe trying to
get rid of the Queen cm
so number part of a porn up before about
nothing now I can destroy it spawns some
pressure on f2 and now may be knighted
to f4 here this would be nice you know
okay by someone or he won four games oh
ok so this game doesn't start sometimes
the technical technical issues so some
weird weird transpositional yeah but is
a couple of tempe down on the Benoni and
this is nice for me really a success a
huge weakness so I'll get into here
immediately now be 7 + f7 hanging oops
alright so I'm second place okay I try
to play e6 as a pre move to have a quick
first move in you can play that against
anything at least you won't lose
something okay it doesn't move I did
press the doubling cube it doesn't react
ok now it does i would have won i know
not even better alright so i'm in the
Lydia the other guy didn't do this call
a pretty good opponent here to want
something ok I've got some some nice
space advantage here but it's nothing
nothing concrete yet yeah interesting
don't not sure maybe taking was also
good
it wants to play be five year ok I can I
can prevent that only been a tad slow
twin Trade I don't mind but he does
no effing 36 weakness to play on
actually the points lost already so we
need two sec here rather loosely
exchange then the important porn if you
grab snow okay I agree blundered I
didn't take it oops yeah okay that's a
bullet game so you don't resign him okay
well resigned so I draw some bullets are
just a bit ridiculous so you just play
on what can you do oops to be cautious
am NOT giving away the Queen so early
yeah this is quite satisfying p Wendy
phone went is he has weakened himself
was g4 for no particular reason yeah
take this temple so what now
want to use the d3 square
take the Queen right here I can actually
threaten any I know i don't want fi x
thought but it doesn't win material
still a good move and now here if you
moves the rock I've d4 check yeah check
and here this is very nice III also
right don't think too long about this
let's get get near the king alrighty
this worked out but the guy in first
place is really winning his game super
quickly I'm not to slower anything
either but he's just winning super
quickly 96 / saying all right yeah this
is somewhat we had set up that I played
here hmm not too bright
don't really know where to go with my
king here
you know I'm just bet here in this
position
I just hope I don't don't lose out right
here could easily happen all right so I
just gave you a very look for nothing
who this was close very bad position
okay
alright so we got some Sicilian by
transposition not sure that this is any
good really but okay in a bullet game
move first thing later
yeah pretty equal equal position I'd say
oh now I'm I have some some play maybe
on d3 year a to also hanging okay now
got c4 and it gets better and better
let's grab this and b2 also also a
problem okay but let's just oh no don't
want to help him with this pawn
structure and now I'm threatening also
e5 yeah pinning here this this this pawn
so oops two points up now
trying to activate the rope here now
Quincy to check made hard to prevent
yeah okay so I'm still on second place
was quite some distance to play three
okay maybe do some one or two games
after first place is really far away
oops and dirty little trickier but ok
it's viable mean I'm bullet took on f3
and I had the pre move already in ok ok
so I'm piece down form for nothing candy
to get off right here oh my the Queen
Nia what am i doing ok but alright so I
got the piece back oh man ok this is a
no very nice from he cannot tickler and
move anything those pawns just just
terrible maybe threaten a day 7
checkmate yeah oh man what a game oh man
yeah okay so let's continue here i have
got to throw some some distance to place
one
some really weird opening him getting
the bishop pair for not much but I
development of course okay can play he
could have played 96 and I'm pretty down
on time and I'd f7 yeah well okay
doesn't do it
wants to go to see 5 bad he is playing
with moose but they're good somehow i
mean i was i was expecting other moves
but but his moves are good well let's
say good enough yeah this was close
really just one more second or one and a
half more seconds of course I spent too
much time on this video Penang okay I
guess that that pretty much seals it for
first place the other guys what 70
points ahead ridiculous 70 points and I
cannot catch this so this guy doesn't
move why don't I get the point after 15
seconds he should be for faded actually
yeah
yeah chessmaster he always plays this
kind of strange stuff yeah black is
actually much better from beginning with
it always costs you some seconds to
actually refute this this nonsense all
right so
I just hate this crap this is still very
questionable for white but I spent so
much time check man next move so I did
it somehow crazy stuff all right I said
it before the tournament it's not like
you can expect brilliant quality here
okay i did w okay f5 of course very much
weakens everything so II 65 and so on so
I should go Bishop c4 castles rookie one
stuff like that okay I don't mind him a
movie the same piece on a note or I
again yeah just play the simple moves
that should be good enough here
okay well maybe I can open it up even
more here it takes on f3 takes on e6
looks pretty dreadful takes on d5 okay
tix here so Bishop there should be six
now rookie for should win material on
the farm I'm a third place yeah someone
overtook took me and first this order
for each really hmm maybe it's on a
fridge somebody hasn't finished to pawn
for a while it we add King f3 is some
really strange move
threatening on h2o which I which I take
maybe he can trap the bishop now I
almost took quick answer to move that ok
let's drop back
how do i get my queen involved or this
is a pin Queen to h4 yeah yeah and no f3
also this wins the house Roxy to only
move and I can take it and drop g1 later
I'm four points now on place one somehow
it doesn't play anymore no idea why
ok some friendship
some quite a quite a nasty Pena try to
open the position up quickly huh maybe I
could have played this also instantly
yeah this looks nice preventing it sir
is canceling here still do now with the
queen who don't want to exchange Queens
but of course it wins all right let's
not take we should have six to come
winning the rook awesome
yeah I'm four points behind place one I
don't know what what he did somehow it
doesn't play or what no idea because it
was pretty much uncatchable was so far
away yeah summer I want to pawn here in
the opening look quite sure this
happened i think it just it just blended
it but it's not the strongest porn ever
it's got quite some some pressure on the
am Bishop before you it's got quite some
pressure on the isolated pawn oh we
didn't exchange anyway so I'm still in
bulleted some still a bit tricky okay
this is helpful rook in one yeah nice I
can exchange something here then rook
here being to be poorness also pretty
much gone k rosaiah I'm actually first
place wow I'm ready I think I think
first player the player was so clearly
in the lead he somehow took a break or
something no idea
I kept I kept losing or what I'm strange
this was bad well simply too took
weekend and capturing and now I've got a
really dreadful position okay but he
plays it very loosely with g-form it's
dangerous but I might give me some
counter chances the am Bishop Bishop e3
and stuff
might this might be okay actually III
bishop and then eat I I can play it to
ya Wow the second allowed g2g tomato how
do we odyssey prevent Quincy to
checkmate without giving me lots of
material d5 young be 55 55 the others i
can just take
all right bajo the other guy overtook me
again I know I play him this this is
chris cook wow I'm so sorry my my disk
space ran out again this is just crap
here and I'm you missed one game against
first place by industry where he
immediately blundered piece because I
was so irritated by the record stopping
or whatever but it has been a fun
tournament anyway I think in 40 seconds
it will be over and here I actually I
got myself in a pretty bad position but
most likely the game won't be finished
yeah this was this was bad I really need
to check the disk space on before I
start a video I had this before a couple
of days ago and I have I forgot again
yeah I've got them in this computer i've
got to some solid state drive which is
very nice for performance but it only
has got ya second place at the end it
only has got a pretty low capacity so I
sometimes need to really think about
getting rid of some some data to to get
new disk space and it ran ran out of
disk space again jus just when I was
playing the the first place guy here
this WC Kasparov yeah I did a very good
job but I had the chance I played him
but with the winner I would have would
have would have actually um could have
been able to get first place alright so
I hope you had some fun I I did cam back
on again sorry for the technical stuff
again this this disc rainfall I was able
to undelete something quickly
but what can you do okay so i'll try
again i hope you enjoyed the video
anyway despite the the technical stuff
um yeah thanks for watching and talk to
you soon with some new video